добрий день мене звуть вася ворони листопад
та суп для дітей та на мага та записати та
так любимо був відсікала для мене шкіра на
книжка з пасік при повернуть і дітей ну так
щось не я і я ставлю перед собою кисть
над завданням крим чикаго газах спливала
сюжету крем ми пустимо їх динамічних
шляхів мені хочеться щоб дитинка шляхом
вертова їжу книжки з знаходила в ній 8 я
для себе і все разу не приховувала
і кисть збереження нафти до насті секрети
встю книжку і відриваю і видала видані
102 лівого на і новий а вийшло
que ya idu ж люблю буду чого виходив і
персі дві частини на слона на ім'я пуговиць i
bleed вже гарний вигляд wikivid моїх читає
чим мені хотілося щоб шкіра на історія
sublime стила кіста їм ці секрети
щоб дітям купила собі знати і що себе
буде з моїм грою і ми дали
і швагер було в засіла б я обожнюю що на
і головні сліди ти не щоб тихо вести на
устілки з чоловік і вала подружжя ти шубі
хотілося спілкуватися тебе книжка кликати
ахлю вважаємося через встромлення з вуст
зневірюся а з малими читати амі і він їх,
and йшов на води та словах lucique'а вану
були думаєте чому точно та розум не
йшли до того ж вона мокра і будемо тобто
здогадується шах лізти в гроші і ось тут
вид буваєте три історії велика
називається хлюст ainsi тут російських не
ілюстрації
прекрасне художниці які ні верстату
і природи тут нас тількін забезпечення то
їм скигликами через копицю і чи шуму ми не
раз писала і просив ішемія писала ставків
дружина
а якщо тут історія виявляється парафії
блакитного попурі
і я вуста не історія виявляється time
нитку від чорного озера коди на землю
прибувають помил кого через аварію
летальних блюдця 2 чужих планет не
прибудете до викликати дрон і груди і за
розкол і показую вам ті книжки 2-ки
звук ним ноги була купа кве тачкою
прибудуть краї мене благим і не хочеться
сказати ще головної ідеї
у моїх книжок був батько любить і не прийду
символу Чикаго але найбільше води і
наших шкільних програм я поважаю те що
дітям зараз тут ось ці тварюки читають
ик прямо-таки рки чи ки ву так треба б
таким сказав голки, юних чому ви не
прочитаєте їх програмних промов було
ціни довідки тварюки в цих наших
листи якихось був камінчики тину писанини
для битої про прагу ти і читатим і дітям
protect українці страждають страждають
плачеті помирають по верт і ціни на екрані
рішення для того щоб howo ти
нормальний нормальних повноцінних людей
не форму йому святому місці українських
дітей як жертву річки ви зараз за
знаєте цих вісь на йому вірних образ
нашої дити такі ж десь стилус вигляд у
їм хочеться читати ці до viii клас не
дтп і книжки їх будуть приходи і
диким і з героєм і і тихоном і будуть цю
теж нього тієї самої себе